And a few reminders to begin with.
Always go to our blog.
That will help answer some of your questions maybe earlier than going waiting for a zoom call.
And on our website, this little feature, if you go to anywhere, any page on our website, this little thing right here, a little spyglass feature.
It gives you the ability to search for anything.
We have a really good search on our site that you can search for your question.
We probably have written a blog about it or something information about your question.
If not, that's what you're the zoom calls are for.
Secondly, if you have any issues with leading religious exemptions for vaccine policies that maybe your work is looking for or friends or family member.
That needs a protocol to help detox from a vaccine or exposure to those that are vaccinated.
We ask that you go to our sister site, my hope for lime.com.
And on the blog, you'll see blog posts that detail information on this.
Very, very, very stealthfully so my hope for lime is our sister site.
We'll go and look.